what's going on everybody welcome to
part 21 of the intermediate Python
tutorial series in this video what we're
gonna be doing is kind of meshing
together a lot of the things that we've
learned up to this point so we're gonna
be talking about iterators iterables
generators special methods and
object-oriented programming all in one
video so let's get started my goal is by
the end of this video you can at least
answer this question is there a
difference between x where x equals
range 5 or x equals you know and this is
a generator because we're in Python 3
and the generator expression of I for I
in range 5 is there a difference between
these two X's which could also be the
question is there a difference between
these this whole thing range 5 and then
I for I in range 5 as the generator
expression you should be able to answer
that by the end even if you don't know
the answer fundamentally or right away
you should be able to know how to how to
find out the answer to that question now
let's say for I in X we're just gonna
iterate through that referent I 0 1 to
thrower just what we expected
now what you might not know is you can
actually you can rather than using a for
loop you can move the the iterator on
your own manually explicitly and the way
that you can do that is with next so we
can actually say next X next X and what
we're doing there is we're like we're
literally moving this aerator the
iterator you can think of it like a
selector or something where it just kind
of moves along once that one at one at a
time especially as you're doing like a
for loop it's just gonna move that
selector one at a time and so what we
can do save it and run that and you'll
see now as we've we've already moved the
selector twice and then we iterate
through it so the way that it works an
iterator as it iterates over an iterable
it's just going to keep going and just
keep doing this like the next next next
next until it reaches a stop iteration
so now let's close this that's the next
function but really all the next
functions doing is calling the next
method the next method it's a dunder
method
gender next so we'll just call dunder
next twice and we'll see the same thing
runs
no surprises there maybe it's a surprise
though that dunder next is a valid
method of X it's there it exists X as an
object everything in Python is an object
Python is an object-oriented language so
we can print actually don't even need to
print we need to say directs because I'm
in the shell here let me say holy moley
we've got a lot of attributes and little
done ders that we didn't even know about
right there just all there right and
you've got all these comparison
operators you've got string if we were
to print it as we are we've got it er
we've got next got a lot of stuff that
maybe we didn't know that was there
okay so so there's that now let's say
let's say okay I know what we can do we
can make our own class and we'll make
our own class that does range and we
just simply we'll just define next and
we'll make our own iterator entirely so
so sometimes you might come up with a
class I couldn't think of a really great
reason why we would iterate over the
blob class so let's just make a really
simple range object basically that that
will just iterate just like kind of like
range it'll do what range does it just
won't be as lovely as the range
generator now so let's do that so let's
say class range exam and then we're
going to define the initialization so
defined in it of course we need to pass
self we're also going to pass and and we
can even pass a step and we'll just make
that a have it give it a default of one
so someone can use it if they want or
not if they don't care now we'll just
say a self dot current we'll just assume
we're always starting at zero that's
another thing that you can actually
change in the range function what
browser the range generator but we're
not gonna worry about that right now so
if like current equals zero self dot n
will equal end here
and then finally self dot step equals
step real simple initialization method
there now we're going to find the inner
method so define dunder and this one's a
real doozy it's gonna be really tiring
to get through it but we'll get through
it
it'll be okay return self
oh man the carpal tunnel I usually I
feel it seventy in at this point alright
so now that we've done the inter method
let's do the next method again we pass
self here and the next method is
actually pretty much where all the logic
goes and basically it's if self dot
current is greater than or equal to self
dot end basically have we reached the
end well if we've done that we need to
raise a stop iteration if we have it
though we're ready to continue so we're
gonna say the return whoops return val
is equal to self dot current this is
what we're actually gonna return I'm
gonna say self dot current plus equals
self dot step and then finally returned
returned about so unfortunately we have
to make a copy of the value before we
can return it right because once you
return that's the end that's the end of
that whatever it's the end of the method
the function whatever when you do a
return so we need to create that return
value but we also need to make that step
so we're copying the value we make the
step then we return that original kind
of copied value so it's kind of
unfortunate that we have to do this but
we do so that's our training example
pretty cool we can test it we can say
for I in range a range exam five print I
save it run that zero one two three four
it will act the same as we've seen
already because we actually we've
explicitly defined our next inator so we
can do things like x equals range five
X dot next and then just to be silly
we'll just say next X and then for I n X
print I make sure that's on screen it is
good okay no surprises
again though we're gonna do X and when
we created this class we made it
just now we just only defined dunder
init under it under next but we've got
all of these other methods right mm-hmm
which is nice
Python just gives it to us right Python
just automatically gives you all these
methods and then you can decide if you
wanted to over overwrite them on your
own as we've pretty much seen how to do
up to this point so interesting now what
if what does that bothers you though
what if you what if you don't want for
whatever reason you don't want these
methods you might be thinking well
that's because we've created this whole
time we've been using these classes and
objects right what if we what if we
create a generator ourselves that isn't
range it's our own generator entirely
what if we did that so let's just delete
all this and I'm gonna close this let's
define a range generator so fine range
gen in this one will just have end just
keep it nice and super simple
we're gonna say current is equal to zero
and then Wow current it's less than
whatever the end is we yield current now
here's why generators are fun we can
yield that current so it's sending a
value then we can do this current lovely
nice I love the old so it can yield
something and then still continue doing
its own little thing so if that doesn't
sound pretty exciting to you I don't
know what does but anyways so there's a
lot of cool things you can do with that
with that behavior but now what we can
use for I in range gen 5
we can of course print I you know we can
also do x equals range in five or I in X
print I okay zero into the four zero one
two three four because we did both of
them at the same time just didn't want
to waste anybody's time I'm gonna
comment out that first one we can still
do X dot next one two three four
nothing fancy there well here's in
here's the interesting thing we could
say let's curiously let's stick der X
let's see what we find four directs may
be surprising to some but at this point
I think you should have expected that
we're just gonna get all this stuff
because Python is an object-oriented
language if we say x equals 5 and then
leader X at this point
Wow look at those done ders right you
just have them all right these all these
nice special methods are given to us for
basically everything in Python this
everything is an object now i've
overwritten x so good job harrison but
anyway we could say x equals range and v
again and we can turn x like and we can
see okay what do we have here we've got
it add under it ER in fact let me I'm
gonna close this just so I can use the
search function just so I can be a
little faster so let's do range in or
first let's do derp derp X since that's
rain X is the range range Jen okay we
have it ur there actually you can't see
that it's off the screen we have it err
sorry if I pointed something that was
off the screen floor then next and next
so X has it err and next we can safely
assume that's that's adorable
now what about I'm gonna just close it
again so I can simply do a search
what about derp
range Jen just range Jen all right we
have all these done ders do we have a
knitter know it er how about next
probably not if we don't have it hitter
right nothing there
what if we did Durer range Jen and then
we actually pass something right an
object is is created from this again
we've got it er and next here okay so
hopefully you can kind of start seeing
some of the differences what about derp
range just the range fun
oh the range generator rather how about
here there's it er and let's search for
next real quick right you've got one
next let me just make that totally clear
Durer range no next but there is an ATAR
interesting what if we der range 5
whoops fine you should already know what
the answer will be but will there be an
inner and a next when we do this
seriously think about it yourself and
then let's run it and there's your it er
and there is no next right okay so yeah
but what if what about what about sorry
we'll do one more one more
and then I'm out I'm gonna leave you to
your own demise I for I in range fine
there you go next in it er
so hopefully hopefully actually I
probably pointed to it and you can see
it's my face was in the way my apologies
hopefully you're following along anyways
but yeah there's your oops that's in it
err and next and my dog okay so
interesting stuff hopefully if I didn't
just answer the question for you you're
really close to figuring out the answer
that question with very interesting
things as we start to kind of peel away
the layers of Python and all the things
that Python gives us just automatically
out of the gate it's pretty interesting
stuff so if you have questions comments
concerns if baby I didn't illustrate
something correctly or if you've got
something cool you want to share with us
leave that below otherwise I will see
you in another tutorial